It's. Okay, we began.
Welcome everyone. It is the
resumption of our cohort update
the video description. It's the
resumption of cohort one of the active
inference textbook group. It's our 14.
Okay, could someone mute Gsuppie or feel
free to say whatever you want to say.
Can you hear me? Yes.
Okay, so sorry, but I'm completely new
to this interface of a gather and
encoder, so I'm not sure
I understand cohort one and cohort two
here because cohort
one, wasn't it the previous one like the
one that start last year?
Well, it's still going on from May till
July. We did chapters one through five.
Now we are in this cohort. So if those
who did not participate in this part,
thanks for the question, but everyone in
general, respectfully, let's try to have
people who are in the cohort participate
in it. Everyone's welcome to join and of
course rewatch, but contributions and
the questions and the chat are probably
best so that we can respect the people
who are continuing on. This is our 14th
meeting and now we're heading into the
second five chapters of the book. Okay,
does any other person want to give
context? Oh, yeah, go ahead.
The current one that is going on right
now is the cohort one and not cohort
two. We are all learning in different
stages. So the previous hour was the
cohort that is focusing on chapters one
through five stage they're in. And now
some of us, a different set of people,
some are joining both. So that's why we
made the meetings convenient, was so
that we could like for many of us who
want to do both, we can join.
But this is a separate set of people.
I see. Yes. Okay,
so cohort two was first and then
this meeting. In this meeting right now,
cohort two was first. Yes. And now is
cohort one, which started correct. We
warmed up with chapters one through
five. Okay, so I
will leave because I subscribe for
cohort two. Excellent. Okay, good.
Thank you so much. See you next time.
Thanks for setting up all this thing.
Okay, bye bye. Yes. Awesome.
Okay, anyone else want to add anything?
We don't need to do a Coda overview.
I would say people who are watching this
recording can look at the live recording
if they want a Coda update that we just
went through for the cohort two's live
meetings. But does anyone want
to give any introductory thoughts?
Otherwise, there's a few ways I think we
can go for this session, but we're here
just to rejoin our activities and
orient towards chapters six or ten.
We can scan through the chapters, we can
have any suggestions or discussions
around ways to approach them. I don't
know.
Rohan and then anyone else?
I was wondering, when are we going to
get to the projects part or discussions
about the projects? Monetics.
Great question. Let's look at the
chapters and see where that first off,
it can happen however you want with
contacting people. And we
can make a sub page like I see exists
here. This looks really awesome. So
people can request a sub page. They can
mention it. That contact them now
or however. So it's up to you for a
project that is under your control.
It can be developed in the open here or
however, you can also participate in
many ongoing projects like active
blockfronts, which also which might all
share this. Our Gitcoin grant
was approved yesterday. So if people are
familiar with this or want to become
familiar, this is a way to provide or
receive support possibly for their
learning in block prints and
contributing to that open source
package.
Does that address what you were
thinking? Were you thinking about these
project ideas or were you thinking more
about the sort of build your own model
approach that will be starting in
chapter six?
No, about the project ideas in the code
of page. That answers my question.
Awesome. Yeah.
There are different types of projects.
Clearly more will be added, but they're
of different they might
involve building a generative model,
but they are not the generative model
itself. Or only let's
look at chapter six because this
is where the generative model
construction is going to come into play.
And so again, there's a lot of projects
that you would only need to
qualitatively think about generative
models for, like educational material
production is related to the generative
model or could be modeled as the
generative model of a learner.
But you wouldn't necessarily have to
make a generative model. But in chapter
six,
it's a recipe for designing active
inference models. It is
going to brock. Sorry, just real quick.
I think Lucas here doesn't have access.
He asked for access. Okay,
message in discord. Or I mean message
and gather your email address and I'll
add you.
Okay,
sorry. Okay, you requested access.
All right, I will add you. That's
enough. Then in
chapter Six, it's going to ask some
questions that are driving
the design of the generative model.
Which system are we modeling? System of
interest, what is the appropriate form
for the generative model reflecting the
discrete or continuous distinction that
we looked at? And also all these other
questions that aren't exactly within the
textbook, like temporal depth,
hierarchical nesting, which parameters
are learned versus fixed? All these
different directions that the models
actually have to be elaborated on even
before getting to the data engineering
and maybe even code implementation.
Just from a structural perspective,
what form is it?
How to set up the generative model is
where some of those analytical details
begin being introduced. Not necessarily
even the program level implementation or
an executable simulation, but like,
okay, we have a preference vector.
Is there two states? Is there some
continuous preference distribution?
Whatever it is, what is the actual
details of the generative model?
And then the other side of the
coinblanket is the generative process.
So what are the endogenous dynamics
and the causal mapping with action for
the generative process?
And there's kind of cases where you have
more of a communication setting, active
inference entities on both sides. You
could also have more of like a simple,
simple partnering,
like two deterministic programs that
send messages to each other. Or it could
be like one more cognitive,
more agent like generative model and one
more environmental nonliving
type.
Any thoughts or overviews? Or how would
people think about how can we make this
type of a recipe design? Should we be
all designing a model? Or how do we even
go about reading a section of the book
in a chapter that begins with a recipe
provision? Lyle yeah,
I spent a lot of time building what I
think would be classed here as
generative models. And what I find is
that I characterize it as the step
of framing up is
often far trickier, sometimes much
harder, frankly, than building a model,
depending on what the situation is.
And in my experience, I find that it all
comes down to making sure we understand
what is the question that we're trying
to answer. It's sort of like because
every modeling process I'm sure
everybody on this call knows is a
process of deciding what to leave out,
right? What to put in, what to leave
out, and what level of representation.
Then everything that's in there,
if it's going to be a good model, has to
be necessary and necessary to
answer a question or provide a
particular insight or so forth. So that
whole issue of framing out what
you're going to build in all those
different the 10,000 questions, there's
more than four. Ultimately it's many.
Then it's all about that, which often
means understanding the audience. If the
model builder is the only audience,
this is much simpler. If the audience is
some much larger group with different
perspectives, a lack of homogeneity
and insight, then there almost has to
be, I'm going to say almost a pre
modeling or framing process of sort of
framing up. What are the questions we
care about? And then we can talk about
how those translate into a model that's
just some general framing.
Thank you. That's very interesting.
It makes me think about this audience
question for the model. Like, why are we
building the model? Why are we shaping
our regime of attention to build this
model? Model building can be an end
of itself. It can be creative and
expressive and fun and all these other
things. And maybe later there's a road
that has some Pragmatic value too. But
also it can just be like fun. Like,
what would a generative model that could
do this look like? And that can be very
didactic there's other times where
you're presenting information, oh, I
made a simulation of Twitter discourse
and dot dot, dot is always going to
be presented in a way that's not only
just like, the model distilling down
from the world, but then you're
communicating it. And then when you're
actually not just communicating, but if
you're making an application that does
something and communication is doing
something as well, then the system
of interest, as Lyle mentioned,
is totally nontrivial. And there's the
whole framing in some of these early
stages, especially because they can't
always be changed easily later.
Rowan and then anyone else.
Yeah, so I'm just curious, when you say
who's the audience,
isn't this part of the active inference
model itself? That okay, so whatever
makes sense in that framework, wouldn't
that be the audience here?
It has to survive, right? Your agent has
to survive. So whatever generative model
helps it survive, would that not be the
it's model of choice over here? And I'm
just curious. I'm not sure it's an
awesome way to frame it, and maybe
someone can share the free energy
governance link in the chat. I just
can't look it up right now. But it
puts this very nicely in a recent pretty
short book dissertation about that
imperative for organizations.
And yes, in one sense it can be said
the right generative model or like the
audience for it is whatever its
survivability conditions are.
And within our textbook group, the
survivability conditions are open.
However, we're also learning about or
even just gesturing towards like,
okay, not just we're going to imagine a
room with a person who can take on a
jacket or take it off. We can make that
a didactic model. And the audience could
be this textbook group or future cohorts
of the textbook group, and the function
could be just sort of like a neutral
exemplar active inference generative
model. But then, of course, the
considerations for information
presentation, empirical data analysis,
any kind of application, the system of
interest is not just the one person with
the jacket on or off two states room
with a sign fluctuation. So that's a
different situation for model building.
So how should we interpret this recipe?
Okay, but is there
not like, a general framework
for what a good generative model looks
like is what I'm saying. I guess you
could frame that differently. So if you
want to build pixel level
representations, for example, you can
use a gan, and that's a pretty decent
one, but maybe pixel level
representations are not good
for the task at hand or something like
that. So it should fit a general
category. Right? So this is what a good
set of models looks like for active
inference. So that's sort of getting at.
Yeah, that's a very fascinating framing.
Does anyone want to add something to
that?
I totally hear you on is there
a rubric like, what are we evaluating
the generative model and process fit?
Because it's not like there's just
simply a best generative model bigger or
whatever. No feature about it except
outside of a generative process.
Context is the fitness and then
what? Is there a rubric? Is there a gold
standard? Is it like, oh, you're dealing
with audio data here's, the file format,
that level of standardization?
Certainly not. However, are there some
practices or lenses that we could bring
in from people's experience with
evaluating model adequacy and relevancy?
There probably are. Lyle well,
yeah, that really comes right back to
purpose, right. So a model is always fit
for purpose.
Of course, this also surfaces the
questions of model validation, right.
One of the things we haven't talked
about here is what's the right model?
How do we frame up the right model?
What do we choose to put in what we
leave out? Part of that is purpose.
And how would I evaluate if I do what
I'm imagining a model will be? How do I
evaluate its quality, its validity?
Well, what data is actually available?
That's one thing you always have to ask
at the outset what data is available?
What data can I use? What's
computationally adequate?
And what parts of this then when we
kind of project, when we apply
this model, if that's its role, then
does it fit for the purpose? Does it
provide good, adequate results and
improve whatever behavior we're trying
to address?
You can't say if it's good if you don't
have a purpose. So if your purpose is
just to explore model building, which is
something I love to do, then that's a
pretty big there's a lot of things that
are fit for that purpose, right? But if
the purpose is to do
a prospective analysis of a system and
what actions might be taken to
intervene, then that's in a different
thing.
Thanks a lot for sharing it. I'm really
happy. And I think it's relevant that
we're having this kind of a discussion
because we've gone through some of the
first chapters and we'll continue
through chapter six, I think, in having
this conversation. But does anybody else
want to add something about this more
general topic of, like,
how are we even coming to talk about
what system, or how are we framing the
system that we're modeling that's
in Section 6.3?
This is too broad. It's not active
inference specific. But whenever I'm
trying to model something, the only
questions that I mean, it is contextual
to the purpose. It entails a purpose in
an audience. But all I want to know
basically is what are the questions that
this model needs to generate an answer
for? What is the
information that is necessarily,
therefore kind of required to model
a system that would have such answers in
it?
And maybe another way to say the same
thing is like, what affordances would
the model require to
answer, address whatever, some set
of questions that are posed to system?
So if you asked,
I don't know,
how frequently does a yellow colored
car, I don't know drive down this
particular road,
then I wouldn't need to record the
number of bikes or their colors that are
using the bike lane or buses or trucks
large. This is maybe
outside the scope of what I mean by
yellow. How many cars
out of all the cars, how many are yellow
or something driving down this road or
whatever, like not
even exactly a generative model. But my
my point is that modeling that system
there, there is obvious data that's
completely irrelevant, right? And so
if you were going to build some sort of
simulation of any kind that's going to
be generative like there's
often a lot of data that's just
completely extraneous depending on what
questions you're going to ask of it.
Thanks. In 63
in the first paragraphs they're going to
come out hard on the interface concept
of Markov blanket. This is how you'll do
system modeling is by finding interfaces
that distinguish the internal and
external states of a system. Then that
is critiqued or elaborated because
there's in infinite degrees of freedom
in the course gradings and those are
modeler specific and
they suggest that that matters.
Especially if you want to be considering
embodied extended perspectives where
just descriptive interfacing
models won't give you the whole answer.
There's a great paper could a
neuroscientist understand a
microprocessor showing that even if you
have total access to the microprocessors
firing like an EEG and a generated set
of single and double lesions, a lot of
the interpretations would be strongly
misleading. Yet people want the wiring
circuit of the brain which is dynamic
and also involves diffusive molecules.
We have all 302 nematode neurons
mapped but that also as an interface
diagram is not even close. So if
you want to describe the nematode like
model building then it's a fit for
purpose. However, there might be very
simple models that could be doing a lot
better in nematode behavior observation.
The form is discussed. There are three
main design choices. First, discrete and
continuous time. We had some awesome
discussions in the previous months about
similarities and differences and where
in theory they're different and then in
practice where they're different. The
whole question of discretizing
continuous systems. The second choice
is between shallow models and
hierarchical models where inference
operates at multiple timescales. The
third choice is the consideration only
of the present kind of the variational
free energy versus models with temporal
depth. Temporal depth consideration
could be purely passive and it could
also include some element of affordance
which if we remember to like the B
matrix actions are influencing how
states of the world are changing through
time. So that is how active inference
is unifying. Policy comparison
by kind of embedding action into
estimates of how things could evolve
probabilistically.
Those three design decisions are
explored in slightly more detail in the
subsections 65. How to set up
the generative model after
specification. Then the specific
variables have to be included. Okay,
the latent state temperature is going to
be continuous. The observations in my
thermometer I'm going to take in as just
integers. And then there's going to be a
person who is going to be in a binary
state of like whether it's hot or cold,
or maybe I want hot, neutral and cold.
Or maybe I want them to have a ten point
scale or I want them to have a scale
that's doing dot, dot, dot that is in
this stage of actually setting up the
generative model and giving a
little bit of color to
what had been just outlined.
It's going to be a nested model with
this continuous variable. And this kind
of a discrete variable.
Here we return to the frog example from
earlier in the book where there's like
but it's kind of being generalized a
little bit. It was introduced with the
whole Bayesian equation walkthrough.
Now we're returning to it and thinking
more about multimodal or like even you
could consider this as sensor fusion
because there's some hidden cause, the
jumping or the action of a frog that is
inducing several domains of
impact potentially in the generative
process. And then that leads to specific
observables from the perspective of
the cognitive entity. Those could be
again, two communicative cognitive
entities or one and not or however so
this is like, okay, we're going to be
modeling forest fires.
So forest fires, they change the
temperature, they change the chemical
composition, they change the vibrations
in the ground or something. Okay, and
then maybe there's three sensors, maybe
you have three thermometers. And then
what about them? Are you going to
average them? Are they going to be like
three parallel modeled time series?
That is where some more specification
of the generative model comes into play.
Keeping the active inference ontology in
mind. What are the affordances of the
frog? What are the latent states that
are being changing through time like
sound, physical presence or photon
emission or something? And then what are
the data? That would be the O, the
observations.
This box looks like it's about different
sensory modalities. I'm sure there's a
lot of interesting discussions we could
bring in here.
Priors and empirical behavior complete
class theorems. Any statistical decision
procedure behavior may be framed as
Bayes optimal under the right set of
prior beliefs.
Discussion of fixed and learned
variables one can imagine the pros and
the cons generally of having fixed and
learned variables. Like computationally
it's simpler to fix hard code a
variable. However, if there's a setting
where the model's adequacy depends on
being able to update that, maybe you
want it learnable. However, then you
have to deal with these questions about
the kinetics of learning like instantly
switch or slow switch or trend
averaging. So there's a lot of
discussions around learning how is
attention regulated, what is precision
on learning? It's like it very much
complexifies the model and there's many
variables that you can bring into a
learnable setting. But when
it's framed as just static variables and
only like the hidden states changing
through time. That's like the simplest
case. But more and more cognitive
entities probably are going to entail
considering learning dynamics,
setting up the generative process.
The reason we postponed the design of
the generative process so little
slate of hands entity first,
not the niche first is that in
many practical applications discussed in
this book, we simply assume the dynamics
of the generative process are the same
or very similar to the generative model.
We generally assume the agent's
generative model closely mimics the
process that generates its observation.
That is clearly a simplifying case
because it doesn't address what
if you're paying attention to predicting
width and the world is dependent on
height. There's so many complexities of
that which is really that broader. Like
what is being modeled, what matters
question but in some
way very upstream or very close to the
stream, it is like the rabbit being put
in the hat. Like if the rat knows that
there's a five x five maze, that's a
huge amount of information versus if it
only has access to pure local
information. And that's just something
to, I think, for us to note as we look
through models. Like are we modeling the
generative process? Oh, so the seasons
oscillate. So it is a sine wave. So then
the generative model of the agent is
also going to be fitting a sine wave.
Well, then it kind of collapses to like
a stochastic regression and maybe
then it looks like the fit is going to
be very good.
Active inference modeling brings in
another complexity with action
influencing outcomes that prevents some,
I guess, fallacies of modeling, but by
no means and probably introduces many
others. Eric? Yeah.
Can you hear me? This is a new sounds
good. So this might be a time to discuss
the question I posted and I apologize I
didn't put it in the right place the
other day. I just figured out today that
it goes under this particular location.
But this is about the question about why
modeling of a generative process is
necessary, is a necessary step for
building an active inference model. So
let me just read it because it's a lot
of words. So we know that an active
inference agent employs a generative
model as its model of the external world
and it uses this generative model to
perform inferences about perceptual
input and to make decisions about
actions. So in general, the external
world is complex and unknowable to the
agent. The generative model may or may
not be able to learn. But if it is
learning is supposed to put the
generative model in a better alignment
with the world's generative process,
whatever that may be. So I can see how
one might model the generative process
if one is building an artificial agent
in a laboratory where you kind of have
access, you control how the world
behaves with respect to the agent. And
then you might want to study how well
the agent design works versus one versus
another under control conditions. But
this is not the same as designing an
agent to go out and cope with some real
world environment where you really don't
know what the generative process is. So
I think that the recipe for designing an
active inference models would include
formally setting up the generative
process only in the kind of the
laboratory situation, but not if you're
really trying to build something out for
the real world because you don't know
the generative process. You might create
an artificial laboratory kind of
situation by trying to build a model of
how the world works and say, well, how
does my agent work under those
assumptions or not? But that might
set you up for putting the agent in the
real world. But in fact, you don't know
the generative process if you're really
trying to build something to work in the
real world. That's my comment, my
question. That's your question.
Thank you, Lyle. Well,
Eric, I love that framing because I
think there's multiple different cases,
right? So I think if you're modeling
something that, as you say, goes in the
real world, then perhaps it's some
sentient creature or being,
then obviously the real world,
even if we knew everything about it, is
too complex to model. Right. So that's
fool's gold to assume you know
everything, right?
I'm just going to say, yeah, that's
hard. Typically, I guess we would say
what are the parts of the generative,
the real world, the generative process
that we're going to consider relevant
and deal with that and knowing that
we're making a leap of faith. But
there's another case, I think, which is
more generalizable, just complex
adaptive systems that operate in what I
call the built world. So I
work with a bunch of people who build
digital twins. They build digital twins
of human infrastructure,
so buildings and all this stuff there.
The generative process that we're
concerned with is largely knowable and
largely representable.
What's interesting about that is there
are a bunch of blind spots and
inadequacies in what we know about that
generative process and the ability to do
inference about what the real state of
that system is then becomes the value of
this approach in that setting.
Right. I don't think
there's a general answer. Once again, I
think it really comes down to purpose
and what the specific framing you're
looking to do? To me, this ability to
say something about what I I like that
idea of decision agents, right.
Decision agents that are going to
potentially take action or infer actual
states is much richer than what a lot of
the historical modeling paradigms have
given us. So I think that's really
interesting. Thank you, Lyle. Ali.
Also think that the distinction between
generative process and generative models
become significant if we want to
simulate learning rather than just
inference. I mean, that's the answer
I got from Ryan Smith because I asked
him almost the same question. Why do we
need generative process in order to
simulate the agents? Because,
you see, for the generative process,
if the generative model exactly maps
them to generative process, we only need
that capital D matrix, right? And that's
just when we're just trying to simulate
the inference side of the agent, right?
But when the learning comes along, then
we need to separate that capital D
from another matrix, probably dill case
D, which maps into the generator
process. So yeah, one of the situations
that the distinction between two might
be necessary is when
those two process, I mean learning and
inference, are taken as two separate
phenomena to model.
Thanks. One note is
also there's work on symmetries in the
generative process, generative model,
like, I think like the bi directional
paper with Matt Sims and Blue discussing
it. And then here
will be a defense to Eric's excellent
question.
The entity first modeling approach
that's taken by this chapter,
one can say, I don't know whether I'm
going to a forest or a desert, but I'm
going to have these sensors on my
designed interface and I'm going
to do extensive modeling on
interoception and homeostasis. And if
I can learn policies that balance
homeostasis, then I've survived.
If I fail, then failure happens.
So that doesn't mean that it works or
it's doing the right thing, fit for
purpose, any of those aspects. But one
of the insights from the four E and the
embodied side is like a vast amount of
our what is modelable as cognitive isn't
necessarily the declarative.
I think, therefore I am possibly
even symbolic type thinking linguistic.
There's a lot going on and many
of that a lot going on can be simplified
by not even knowing about the external
process, maybe not even the as modeled
kidney knowing about what the as modeled
liver is doing. So this
type of a focus where it's like we're
going to define our
entity types and
the kinds of observations that they can
make, the kinds of affordances that they
have or do empirically or that they
conceptually could do.
That approach is
consistent with embodied biological
systems and persistence of
organizations. And so
I'm wondering how that piece comes into
play with this discussion that's very
important about and also their earlier
discussion of the embedded and extended
cognition is that it kind of blurs the
line with what is a generative model,
what is a generative process. So hence
there being a lot of thinking
and attention on what the system's
modeling is. What are the known unknowns
and the unknown unknowns going to be.
Let's just see how the chapter
ends.
Six, seven simulating, visualizing,
analyzing, and fitting data using active
inference. So standard routines
for active inference that provide
support for all functions are available.
Hashtag SPM and Appendix C
step by Step model is a great look
through this. This is MATLAB code one
amazing work that we could all iterate
on. Would be porting MATLAB into
the ontology into Python and
or Julia with Pi MDP or active
blockference. But there's a lot
in SPM and some of it's neuroimaging
specific, some of it's very variational
base specific. Not all of it is going to
be state of the art or the most useful
in every situation. However,
I wonder if only offering certain
routines in MATLAB, which is like a
traditionally very academic software
platform and potentially non free,
can be a limiting factor. So those
who feel like they want to learn more or
contribute this way helping structure
some of the code architecture so that
cohorts coming through can be doing
multiple language. Maybe first we can
just move some of these routines into a
folder and then people can start to
organize those types of aspects.
Summary it's a four step recipe.
We walk through it from the
consideration of the system of interest
broadly, like the entity and the
process, focusing in on the entity
specifically thinking structurally about
what it is going to be like doing
composed of specifying that to a few
levels of detail, then doing the same
for the generative process. And then
once that is specified, it's not quite,
quite there for most people today,
but where it seems like
they are laying out a path towards and
where we probably can and will be after
that level of setup. In some
potentially graphical editor or
parameter file. Then,
as SPM and MATLAB have done in many,
many papers, the generative model
specification almost prepares the
working script. But there's still a lot
of details and pieces to add in,
especially in a modern environment and
for all of these non standard and novel
cases that people are wanting to
consider. But that is once we have a
notebook that goes through the recipe,
then the recipes can be forked and so on
and they can be written in different
languages, pi MDP, block for instance.
Ali. Yeah,
just one thing that I think is not made
explicit in this chapter is that
actually that first step, which system
are we modeling? Especially the
identification of the markup blanket
part is basically at this point of
active inference research is more like
a hypothetical step because I
also had the misapprehension that we can
somehow identify the markup
blankets from data. But then as
I went on through my project and by
consulting Maxwell and others actually
this is the comment Maxwell made about
my proposal that he said that
identifying markup blanket from data is
still an outstanding issue that
is not resolved yet in the research
on active inference. And one of the most
active areas, areas of research they're
doing at Versus Lab is just focused on
this part of the modeling recipe. I mean
how we can identify,
automatically identify or somehow learn
the markup blanket from just pure data
points. Awesome. And that
ties in with Dalton s's work on the
blanket index and like continuous
variables for dynamic assemblies of
blanketing. This is going
to get really nuanced and
empirical with the discovery
and the thresholding of Markov blankets
and causal inference in real world
systems with many different kinds of
sensors and doing structure learning on
generative model and process and like
everything empirically. Which is why,
as a simplifying step,
it actually really reminds me of how
Dave Snowden situates the difference
between systems thinking and complexity
thinking. Which is systems often uses,
like, a lot of nodes and flowcharts to
represent system elements and
relationships and interfaces,
whereas in complexity and the Knevin
especially framing, it's more
like self organizing sand dunes.
And so causal relationships might
be very much in flux and it puts a
higher focus on action rather than
system description, especially in
situations like moving your head where
the relationship of different things is
going to be heavily action dependent.
And so for now, we're kind of in the
systems world where it's like a priori,
here are the system interfaces and then
we're going to take whether it's a
heuristic or whether you take a literal
interpretation, but you don't have to.
You could just say I'm taking
heuristically the approach of the
system's mapping. But that's not
to say that that generative model
couldn't be trained in a systems mapped
context and then placed into
a different setting where there was a
mismatch or a different generative
model. And so it's going
to be an ongoing discussion. When are
these lines drawn? One other point,
other than not needing to use last names
to refer to specific concepts,
like are we talking about the blanket
that statistically insulates every
partition of nodes in these Bayes
graphs, which are going to be vast? As
Ali and Yaakov and I were discussing on
the branching time active inference from
just a few days ago yesterday, these
graphs are going to be vast. And so
just saying there will be a Markov
blanket. In fact, there will be many
Markov blankets with different semantics
that you might assign to them or not.
How does that map onto the real world?
Is like the realism, instrumentalism,
pragmatism abduction conversation that
we've been having? Do you come in with
these kinds of boundaries,
heuristically and distinctions or
how many levels of uncertainty and
nesting? I don't know how many
categories of blank there are. I don't
know if it's a category or a continuum
of this. You can actually still
take on multiple levels of uncertainty
in the modeling, but then fitting it
with empirical data, if it's fit for
purpose use is to do some sort of
statistical inference or like provide
meaning or action, but just
didactically. When the model's purpose
is educational, then there's a lot of
things and architectures we might play
with and then the
recipe. And also this conversation
helps, I hope, hold space for the
educational and the curiosity driven
model development where we're going to
have a lot of fun and interesting GMs
and people's applications
and working with different real world
constraints and different
settings. We'll all be learning a lot
from it, and hopefully some of it will
be in repos we can reference.
Other people may want to play around and
version within folders that we can make
if anybody wants to be added as a
collaborator in this textbook
repo, which is just pretty much empty
except for, I guess, a script from
Yaakup.
And there'll be more to say on probably
GitHub. And as we continue
through. But in these last minutes,
does anyone have any thoughts for our
continuation of the cohort?
I have one question. Daniel, you
referenced a paper earlier in the
discussion that I'd love to
get the reference to about persistence
of organizations and survivability. Oh,
yes.
All right. I will put it into
resources.
Here's the work.
It's a PhD dissertation that was
published as a book, and I'll upload the
PDF as well. This is extremely
interesting work.
Yeah, it just came out and and okay,
in our last minutes, it's it's too, too
fun not to share.
So Karl Friston has written a
foreword.
What is a firm's purpose? What is an
organization's purpose? It's as
difficult to answer as why am I here?
Free energy, governance and the FEP.
Inverts the question, instead of asking
how must the system behave to survive?
It asks, how do systems that survive
behave? The answer is rather
deflationary. They survive. Their
purpose is just sustainability. So some
classic Fristinisms,
some very nice framings on page
95.
There's some great juxtapositions.
So it's always awesome to see this
kind of quality work.
And who knows what people here will
see? And I don't see any scripts here,
thus the textbook. But who knows?
Maybe we can do some generative modeling
of organizations or we can specify
it and iterate on it,
realize it in block, for instance, and
Pymdp and for any lab and JF's symbolic
suite.
So there'll be a lot of fun things to
explore this cohort.
Any other questions or ideas that people
want to share?
Thanks. And congratulations to people
for joining this continuation. It's a
great continuance. And and
I know that this part is going to be
very interesting. The next three months
will be interesting.